hier wurde unmöglich ist möglich gemacht
neil armstrong und buzz aldrin betreten
als erste menschen den mond mit hilfe
der fähigsten wissenschaftler ihrer zeit
verdammt viel geld und vor allem durch
die bis heute größte rakete aller zeiten
die saturn 5
der erste start ist mittlerweile 53
jahre her
und trotzdem ist dieser ton 5 das
leistungsfähigste trägersystem das
jemals geflogen ist die saturn 5 stand
110,6 meter hoch und konnte bis zu 140
tonnen fracht in die niedrige
erdumlaufbahn befördern
es muss mega spannend gewesen sein
damals die apollo-mission miterlebt zu
haben
leider bin ich und wahrscheinlich auch
viele von euch zu jung um die
mondlandung live gesehen zu haben
aber das macht nichts denn der nächste
meilenstein der menschheitsgeschichte
steht kurz bevor das nächste kapitel der
raumfahrt ist klar wir wollen zum mars
und da gibt es gerade zwei raketen die
der saturn 5 konkurrenz machen wollen
zum einen ist da das von der nasa
konzipierte sls das space launch system
soll uns erst mal zum mond und dann
später eventuell auch zum mars bringen
es steht ganz 65 zentimeter höher als
dieser von 5 und könnte damit mal die
größte rakete aller zeiten werden
es kann allerdings nur 130 tonnen fracht
in die niedere erdumlaufbahn bringen
wird also immer etwas im schatten der
saturn 5 stehen und dann gibt es da noch
die private raumfahrt das starship von
spacex dass das schiff soll die
menschheit in den nächsten 20 jahren zum
mars bringen überschall reisen auf der
erde ermöglichen und tatsächlich auch
die artemis mission zum mond
unterstützen
es könnte also echte konkurrenz für das
sls werden wenn das alles nach plan
läuft dann wird das starship die größte
rakete aller zeiten sie wird nochmals
zehn meter höher als die saturn 5 kann
noch mal zehn tonnen mehr transportieren
und es zu allem überfluss auch noch
komplett wieder verwendbar
aber wie kann das eigentlich sein wie
kann space ex ein privates
raumfahrtunternehmen mit nur einem
bruchteil des budgets etwas schaffen was
die nasa nicht geschafft hat um uns in
den nächsten 20 jahren zum mars zu
bringen muss das starship scheitern
es wird explosionen geben es wird
verpasste deadlines geben und es wird
misserfolge geben und das ist gut so
warum das erklärt euch heute bei doktor
watson
[Musik]
[Applaus]
los ging's map maker sticks seine trier
[Musik]
dieses video wird unterstützt von pfizer
ich bin ja mal gespannt wie die großen
raketen im intro gerade bei euch
angekommen sind denn so was wollten sie
eigentlich schon immer mal machen und
jetzt mit favre hat es endlich geklappt
pfeiffer ist ein online marktplatz wo
ihr freelancer aller art finden könnt
ihr euch bei den verschiedensten
projekten unterstützen können hier
findet ihr wirklich für jedes
erdenkliche problem den passenden profil
wir haben zum beispiel super schnell ein
fixes gefunden mit dem wir dann unseren
kleinen traum umsetzen konnten nämlich
eine richtig hochwertige 3d animation im
video zu haben
das ist doch nur eine einfache rakete
oder drei einfache raketen das höre ich
schon sagen aber tatsächlich ist das gar
nicht so einfach
ich habe ja film studiert und um so eine
animation zu machen muss man tatsächlich
erst mal die ganze szene in 3d tracken
dann 3d modelle von raketen finden oder
sogar selber kreieren regen und texturen
und dann noch die richtige licht
stimmung anpassen damit die rakete
hoffentlich so aussieht als würde sie im
park neben mir stehen und auch dafür
braucht man wieder 3d fotos und dias und
super kompliziert und für all das haben
wir uns hilfe geholt dafür sind wir
einfach auf fifa.com gegangen haben nach
3d vfx effekten gesucht und uns durch
die verschiedenen profis geklickt es
gibt ja immer ziemlich viel auswahl
günstig und gut oder etwas teurer aber
dafür dann auch in premium qualität und
wahrscheinlich habt ihr auch schon mal
solche war vergleichs videos gesehen wo
man jetzt gesehen kann das richtig gute
ergebnisse nicht immer teuer sein müssen
das coole ist man kauft ihr nicht
einfach die katze im sack bei jedem job
könnt ihr zwischendurch feedback geben
ob das projekt in die richtige richtung
geht oder ob ihr anstelle einer rakete
vielleicht doch lieber einen riesigen
goetzeler haben wollte und am ende
bezahlt er erst wenn ihr mit dem
ergebnis zu 100 prozent zufrieden sein
schaut mal beifall war vorbei hier ist
wirklich für jedes projekt und jedes
budget etwas zu finden alle weiteren
infos einen link zur website und einen
link zum vfx la der uns die raketen
gemacht hat findet ihr unten in der
video beschreibung seit 2012 arbeitet
spacex an stars einer schwerlast
trägerrakete aus zwei stufen
ihren namen verdankt sie der zweiten
stufe dem eigentlichen stars
das ist ein langstrecken passagier und
frachten raumschiff in dem knapp 100
menschen platz haben sollen so viele
passagiere in einem raumschiff das war
bisher undenkbar
zum vergleich mit der saturn 5 sind
immer nur drei astronauten geflogen die
erste stufe des das schiff ist die
superheavy
das ist eine booster stage also eine
extrem leistungsfähige rakete die das
eigentliche starship ins weltall hilfen
soll das macht sie mit 31 sogenannten
raptor triebwerken die jeweils 310
tonnen schub haben
damit könnte so ein einzelnes raptor
triebwerk 172 autos oder sogar eine
komplette boeing 747 in die luft stemmen
hier sieht man übrigens wie sich diese
rapture engines sind das kann
wahrscheinlich beim intro nicht ganz so
gut rüber aber eine 120 meter hohe
rakete ist verdammt groß das ist quasi
ein wolkenkratzer
besonders beeindruckend wird das im
vergleich zu einer anderen rakete von
spacex nämlich der falcon heavy wer
dachte dass das beeindruckend war fällt
den heavy ist mit 70 metern höhe
quasi ein zwerg im vergleich zum star
und aufgrund von verzögerungen bei der
entwicklung und dem schnellen
fortschritt beim starship wird fällt ihm
her wie jetzt wahrscheinlich kaum noch
gebraucht die felton harry war zwar von
anfang an als übergangslösung gedacht
aber dass sie so schnell wieder abgelöst
wird das hätte man wahrscheinlich nicht
erwartet spacex überholt sich mit seinen
raumschiffen quasi selber nach angaben
der space ex-präsidentin green shotwell
soll das erste starship nur die spitze
des eisbergs seien
in zukunft soll es eine ganze serie von
star chefs geben eines größer als das
andere
und im gegensatz zur feld hinein soll
die superheavy und auch das dach
komplett wiederverwertbar sein
übrigens wenn ich interessiert wie die
feld hinein die raumfahrt für immer
verändert hat dann schaut euch gerne
dieses video hier von mir an space ex
hofft aktuell dass man das da steht für
gerade mal zwei millionen dollar starten
lassen kann
900.000 dollar davon gehen alleine für
den treibstoff drauf das ist natürlich
eine riesige menge geld aber dadurch
dass sich das schiff wieder verwenden
lässt ist das tatsächlich bedeutend
günstiger als das was die nasa für einen
start des sls ausgibt denn da soll ein
staat ungefähr ein bis zwei milliarden
dollar kosten also mal eben das 500 bis
1000 fache des tasche
man könnte also theoretisch anstatt das
sls einmal starten zu lassen
1000 flüge
mit dem starship machen und da eine
andere variante des chips das starship
angeles auch für die artemis mond
missionen der nasa in betracht gezogen
wird müssen sich das sls und die nasa
preislich sehr warm anziehen
das setzt natürlich voraus dass space
extraction nur zwei millionen dollar
starten kann
und da sind noch einige experten in der
branche sehr sehr skeptisch weil sie
übrigens ein video über die artemis
missionen sehen wollt dann schreibt mir
das gerne mal unten in die kommentare
wir haben schon ein bisschen auf
instagram darüber berichtet aber in den
ganzes video dazu sehen wollt dann
machen wir das sehr sehr gerne aber
zurück zum thema wir wollen zum mars und
dass das schiff könnte als die rakete
geschichte schreiben die die menschheit
zum mars gebracht hat welche bemannten
rakete wirklich als erstes auf dem roten
planeten landen wird das weiß heute noch
keiner aber schon in den nächsten 20
jahren soll laut space 6 die erste
autarke statt auf dem mars gebaut werden
das wäre ein meilenstein für die
menschheitsgeschichte denn damit
entwickeln wir uns zu einer multi
planetaren spezies
für die mars mission von spacex startet
das schiff mit hilfe der superheavy
darauf ihnen trennt sich die booster
stage von dem starship und kehrt zur
erde zurück
sobald der starship den orbit der erde
erreicht hat trifft es auf einen tanker
raumschiff das kurz nachdem starship
gestartet ist und das tankschiff fühlt
dann dass das stück wieder auf und kehrt
auch zur erde zurück dieses
vollautomatischen die wut zwei
raumschiffe wurde übrigens schon bei der
dreck into mit der iss erfolgreich
durchgeführt das wieder aufgefüllt ist
chip kann jetzt die reise zum mars
antreten und das wird ungefähr sechs
monate dauern wenn das schiff angekommen
ist dann ist der tag natürlich leer
damit es sich auf dem roten planeten
wieder voll tanken kann hat man sich für
eine besondere kraftstoff modifikation
entschieden anstatt flüssigen
wasserstoff in verbindung mit flüssigem
sauerstoff zu verwenden wird das
starship mit einer verbindung aus methan
und flüssigen sauerstoff betrieben
das liegt einerseits daran dass es
wahrscheinlich möglich sein wird methan
auf dem mars herzustellen
andererseits hat flüssiger wasserstoff
eine viel geringere dichte als
verflüssigtes methan das heißt für
wasserstoff broich das einfach einen
größeren tank aber wie gewinnen wir
methan und sauerstoff auf dem mars
theoretisch wäre es machbar dass auf dem
mars vorkommen der ice abzubauen und mit
wasser elektrolyse in sauerstoff und
wasserstoff zu spalten
der sauerstoff würde dann verflüssigt
und eingelagert werden und aus dem
wasserstoff könnte man zusammen mit
kohlendioxid aus der mars atmosphäre im
sogenannten sabbat prozess methan
produzieren das beim sabbat prozess
entstehende wasser würde dann wiederum
der elektrolyse zugeführt werden und die
benötigte energie für all diese prozesse
soll durch solarkraftwerke auf dem mars
kommen
dafür muss der mars aber natürlich erst
einmal besiedelt werden es braucht
häuser pflanzen menschen nahrung eine
menge ressourcen viele musk rechne mit
einer million tonnen die wir auf dem
mars bräuchten um eine autarke stadt
aufzubauen
das sind ungefähr 1000 flüge mit dem
starship von der erde zum mars und
erinnert ihr euch noch daran was ein
staat mit dem sls kostet genau bis zum
tausendfachen für das gleiche geld das
die nasa für einen start des sls ausgibt
könnte spacex also einfach mal eben alle
flüge für die besiedlung eines anderen
planeten bezahlen
das ist natürlich etwas übertrieben wie
gesagt kann man aus guten gründen
hinterfragen ob spacex wirklich für so
wenig geld starten kann
und dann ist auch noch nicht ganz klar
was es kostet die jeweiligen rücken
vom mars zur erde zu machen aber
trotzdem es zeigt wie teuer das sls ist
beziehungsweise wie viel günstiger space
ex gerade die raumfahrt macht ein
weiterer cooler fun fact ist dass das
schiff von einem weltraumhafen auf dem
meer vor der küste von texas starten
könnte das lässt sich zumindest aus
einer stellenanzeige von spacex
entnehmen
hier wird übrigens auch davon gesprochen
dass das schiff als reisemöglichkeit auf
der erde zu benutzen von texas könnte es
also mit 27.000 km h nach australien
gehen oder von new york nach shanghai in
nur 39 minuten ein normales flugzeug
braucht für diese strecke momentan 15
stunden
okay das ist schon alles ziemlich
ziemlich cool aber aktuell gibt es noch
kein richtiges starship man kann es also
losgehen
in erster linie braucht das ganze
projekt enorm viel planung aktuell
werden erstmal viele tests mit
prototypen gemacht der erste testflug
mit einem richtigen starship soll dann
2021 passieren wenn das alles so kommt
es gibt unzählige kritiker und auch ich
bin ja immer mal wieder skeptisch wenn
es um ihre maske und seine deadlines
geht ok fassen wir das ganze trotzdem
mal zusammen dass starship soll die
leistungsfähigste rakete aller zeiten
werden die meiste last transportieren
können und als erstes bemanntes
raumschiff auf dem mars landen und dass
das schiff kann komplett wieder
verwendet werden und auf dem mars wieder
aufgetankt werden weswegen die kosten
pro transportierter kilogramm extrem
gering sein sollen
aber all das könnte sich ganz schnell
ändern und das hat einiges mit der
philosophie von spacex zu tun
die entwicklung vom starship hat mit dem
ziel angefangen eine wiederverwendbare
rakete zu entwickeln die die menschheit
auf einen anderen himmelskörper bringen
sollen
soweit erst mal alles normal aber von
diesem ziel an wurde rückwärts
gearbeitet
für ein so ambitioniertes ziel braucht
es natürlich leistungsfähige triebwerke
mit dem raptor triebwerken wurde die
grundlage für das starship gelegt und ab
dann hat sich das deutsche projekt zu
einem design spielplatz für spacex
entwickelt nichts ist in stein gemeißelt
alles was nicht optimal ist wird
angepasst oder wie ihre maske sagt ist
der design des taking to long oder
design das rohr und so geschehen in
sachen die für die staatliche raumfahrt
und denkbar wären space action sich
nicht davor komplette design grundlagen
einfach hinzuschmeißen oder anzupassen
zum beispiel die außenhülle aus
rostfreiem stahl anstatt kohlefaser zu
fertigen
für das sls der nasa ist man auf
fördergelder angewiesen das bedeutet
alles muss von vorneherein geplant sein
um es politischen geldgebern
vorzustellen und die investieren am
liebsten in einen vollständigen plan
denen sie überblicken können deswegen
ist das sls schon jahre in der planung
und wird zu 99 prozent so aussehen wie
man es sich damals überlegt hat dadurch
das beste ex privat und nicht öffentlich
finanziert wird können sie vor allem
eins machen risiken eingehen das macht
das starship unberechenbar auf die
interessanteste art und weise klar ist
basics hat auch pläne wie es weitergehen
soll aber jeder nächste schritt baut auf
den ergebnissen des vorherigen schritt
auf wenn sich zum beispiel morgen
herausstellen sollte dass eine andere
treibstoff modifikation besser ist dann
wird spacex nicht davor zurückschrecken
das starship radikal um zu designen
es wird nicht an schritt 3 gearbeitet so
lange schritt 2 nicht fertig ist und
schritt 4 und 5 sind theoretisch geplant
hängen aber komplett davon ab was
schritt zwei und drei für ergebnisse
bringen das ist das komplette gegenteil
vom sls und der nasa denn dort sind
schritte 1 bis 5 seit jahren festgelegt
für das das bedeutet das dass wir noch
einige rückschläge sehen könnten und es
wird vielleicht auch weitere explosion
geben aber aus fehlern lernt man eben am
besten und im gegensatz zum sls und der
nasa werden misserfolge bei spacex
erwartet man könnte also fast sagen dass
es scheitert sich langsam zum mars viele
masken schließlich selber scheitern ist
eine option wenn nichts schief geht dann
innovest du nicht genug
das ist ein revolutionärer ansatz für
die raumfahrt der uns aber auf einen
anderen bewohnbaren planeten bringen
könnte
genau deswegen bleibt es auch erstmal
offen ob space ex den eigenen zeitplan
einhalten wird
es kann ständig irgendetwas aufkommen
das dafür sorgt dass das budget noch
einmal komplett umgekrempelt werden muss
insgesamt so der gedanke soll man auf
diese art und weise aber schneller zum
mars kommen
noch im juni hatte maske in einer
rundmail an alle mitarbeiter klar
gemacht nach dem erfolgreichen fällt im
flug zur iss hat das starship oberste
priorität
über weitere updates zur mars mission
von spacex halten möchte natürlich auch
doktor watson ständig auf dem laufenden
manche update ist für ihn allerdings
kein ganzes video deswegen könnt ihr uns
gerne auf instagram folgende posten wir
jeden tag aktuelle und ausführliche news
aus weltall wissenschaft und technologie
und geben uns einmal ganz ganz viel mühe
wenn also was dem thema space sex und
starship passiert dann erfahrt ihr dass
da auf jeden fall als erstes und jetzt
bin ich mal auf eure meinung gespannt
was glaubt ihr wird das da steht die
erste rakete auf dem mars oder doch eher
das sls der ehemalige chef der nasa ist
übrigens nach langer zeit als verfechter
des sls inzwischen der meinung dass das
sls verschwinden wird und den raketen
der privaten unternehmen platz machen
soll
was meint ihr dazu trotzdem gerne in die
kommentare ich freue mich schon mit euch
zu diskutieren
ansonsten wie immer bis dahin bleibt
neugierig patrick